会思考，
就把你当成你同事没欺负你，
你说你坏话也没惹上你，
你上来给人甩脸色的话，
那你算老几？
我凭什么要看你的脸色？
我肯定不跟你交朋友啊，
这这么简单的逻辑，
你可以有自己的脾气，
但是你的脾气不要去侵害别人的情绪领地，
就是你可以有自己的脾气，
你关起门来你自己甩脸色，
你别给别人看你的脸色，
因为你给别人看你的脸色，
就相当于你用你的脸色去侵害了别人的情绪领地，
侵害了别人的情绪空间。
主要就是有两个问题吧，
第一个是我自己性格上的问题，
就是我现在毕了两年工作了，
我自己也承认我脾气特别不好，
因为一点小事就经常生气，
然后一生气都不爱说话，
以前可能朋友都惯着我，
然上班的时候我也想改工，
但是我就是坚持不了几天，
就这样，
昨天就就得跟我走，
大班的同事因为很早一件事要吵起来，
他走的时候把门一摔，
他跟我说，
说像我这样的人就是不会有人喜欢我的那种，
然后就走了，
我昨天晚上就一整晚就因为这个话一直睡不着，
我也知道我性格有问题，
但是我也不知道我这个怎么改，
也不是他一个人跟我说，
他人也有，
我特别推荐你去看那个被讨厌的勇气，
被讨厌的勇气里面有很多东西的话，
我觉得你可以反复听，
而且反复听不同的博主去分析，
有的时候觉得性格呀，
脾气呀，
很多东西都是由我自己来决定。
你的有的时候发脾气变成了一个手段，
我们要学会去分析，
我自己举个例子啊，
说你们董事长在你面前，
你不太可能冲着董事长发脾气，
对不对啊，
如果说以前有导师班主任，
你不太可能冲着班主任和导师发脾气，
对不对？
所以发脾气就是这个事情是可以控制的，
我有时候就是因为咱小然师生气的时候不常说话，
都不理他们，
我导师也很讨厌我都每次一生气，
我都不说话，
不理人，
这个确实需要我们自己去改。
举一个例子吧，
我们换位思考，
如果说把你换做是另外一个人，
人家也没惹你，
人家也没欺负你，
人家也没得罪你，
上来甩个脸色，
你心里舒服吗？
换位思考，
就把你当成你同事没欺负你，
你说你坏话也没惹上你，
你上来给人甩脸色的话，
那你算老几？
我凭什么要看你的脸色？
我肯定不跟你交朋友啊，
这这么简单的逻辑，
你可以有自己的脾气，
但是你己的脾气不要去侵害别人的情绪领地，
就是你可以有自己的脾气，
你关起门来，
你自己甩脸色，
你别给别人看你的脸色，
因为你给别人看你的脸色，
就相当于你用你的脸色去侵害了别人的情绪领地，
侵害了别人的情绪空间。
你关起门的呀，
上厕所的时候啊，
门一锁，
你垮脸呀，
垮脸随便垮，
随便甩脸色，
甩给马桶看，
甩给镜子看，
甩给手机看都可以，
但你不可以甩给别人看，
你甩给别人看的话，
确实是破坏了别人的心境，
破坏了别人的心。
嗯，
姐妹们啊，
真的，
我现在有一种什么感觉呢？
就是我如果要甩脸色的话，
我一定想想我甩脸色要达到什么目的，
如果我甩脸色能让我多挣点钱，
如果我甩脸色能让我老公给我多点钱，
给我买什么东西的话，
我可以甩一下，
如果我甩这个脸色根本就没有好处的话，
我坚决不能轻易甩这个脸色，
为什么？
因为甩脸色它是我的工具，
你们去看那个最讨厌的勇气就明白了。
就举个例子，
妈妈正在冲孩子发脾气，
冲孩子吼，
但如果说妈妈一听电话，
电话那头是班主任，
是校长，
妈妈马上就能够换一副姿态，
就能够好好的跟班主任讲话，
就能客客气气的跟校长讲话，
一放完电话了之后，
他马上又换成一副发脾气的姿态，
那说明什么问题？
发脾气这个事情是我们的工具，
他不是我不可控制的，
是我能控制的，
都是我的工具。
我发脾气甩脸色的时候，
我先想想，
我甩这个脸色能让我多挣钱吗？
我甩这个脸色能让我得到什么？
不能得到老娘这个脸色不能轻易甩，
甩脸色也是我的工具，
明白了吗？
以后就用这种方法反复的暗示自己，
我先想想我甩这个脸色能为我争取到什么？
争取不到的话，
我的脸色不能甩给别人，
轻一看，
甩脸色也是我的功能，
也是我的工具。
记得啊，
要发脾气的时候，
咱备着点儿人，
咱跑到那个洗手间，
跑到自己的小工位上，
就不要让别人看到，
因为让别人看到你无缘无故的甩脸色的话。
是对别人的情绪的一种讲解，
明白了吗？
也可以多看看心理的书籍，
多跟那个心理咨询师多聊一聊，
嗯，
好，
还有一个事情就是我现在这个工作我家里人很满意，
我，
我是在一个事业单位，
每个月的话可能到时候1万多一点，
我家里人特别满意这个工作，
就让我一直要坚持留在这里，
因为我这个工作他有时候就是一直跟人打交道，
就也很危险，
不是说身体上的险，
就是有的时候就是经翅会有人录音啊什么的，
我之前还有个同事因为这个事情，
哎事官司啊什么的，
就是我一直很害怕，
我不想去干这个了，
但是我家里人也不同意，
我觉得既然是事业单位，
我就是公事公办所有的事情啊，
不要夹杂什么情绪情感，
就是公事公干，
这个事儿能干我就干这个事儿，
该怎么干就怎么干，
我说的每一句话，
发的每一条消息，
就以别人会录音，
别人会截屏为一个标准去干这个事儿，
不轻松多了，
我再说一遍啊，
只要是在工作上，
只要是跟工作相关的事情，
我就以这个标准来要求我自己，
我说的每一句话，
我发的每一条消息，
我接的每一个电话，
都有可能被别人当成呈堂正控，
我就以这个标准来要求自己，
只要符合我的职业标准，
符合法律规定，
没有任何问题，
公事公办的干好，
那就这样啊，
好，
拜拜王飞，
这种状态已经坚持快20年了，
就是我发的每一。
一条短信，
我打的每一个电话，
我心里就想，
如果有一天我这条短信曝光了，
我这通电话曝光了，
你也挑不出来我的毛病，
你也抓不住我的把柄，
我就是以这种状态在工作的，
因为我干律师工作的，
你知道干律师工作最害怕的是什么吗？
最害怕的不是别人，
最害怕的是自己的客户反水，
谁能懂这个点？
尤其是做刑事律师的，
最害怕就是客户反水，
你可能在客户的时候，
你教他这样，
教他那样，
他到时候一反水的时候，
这都是律师教我的啊，
你分分钟坐牢。
记得点赞关注哦。